Speaker 1: All right. Let's get into the mailbag.
It is Friday. Time to look at what some of you
wrote to me over the last week. You can email
info at David Pakman dot com. Leave a YouTube
comment. Leave. Leave anything. Quite frankly,
we might use it. First one we sometimes start
with something negative. I know the first one
today is from Jordan, who is doing the right
thing. He's using the wrong. You're in hate mail,
which is almost required at this point. You're a
bozo while you are. Jordan writes to me, Do you
really think you have everything figured out? Joe
Biden has been on hibernation since 2020, and this
country is a powder keg. Not a powder keg. It's a
powder keg. Just once, I'd want to see you honest
with your audience by putting on clown makeup and
a skirt. If you love Biden so much, you should
go to sleep every day. Well, you know, Jordan,
I do go to sleep every day. I think sleeping is
really important. And it is stunning to me how
someone like this can hold any job, any job. Some
of these folks could be your kid's teachers. They
might be your accountant. Now, maybe Jordan
doesn't have a job. I don't know, but. Let's
move on. I was surprised, but I guess not really.
You know, we launched the Spanish YouTube channel
last week. Quite literally within minutes of the
Spanish YouTube channel launching, I got my first
hate Spanish email where Alexander wrote to me
Communist that iho there puta sung Masuda, which
means son of a bitch Communist trash blood.
I have trashy blood, folks. Don't you say
anything about my blood until you see
my CBC results and you'll be stunned.
No, listen, in all seriousness, the Spanish
content is triggering people left and right, and
it's wild. And I told you, there's a lot of right
wing conspiracy theories targeted at the Spanish
speaking community. And that's why we've taken
on this Spanish language dubbing project. Over a
thousand of you have already subscribed. If you've
got friends, family, parents, cousins, whoever,
who wants to be getting content like what we
create, but they would rather get it in Spanish
than in English. Tell them about David Pakman
dot com slash Spanish David Pakman dot com slash
Spanish. Scott wrote in about my mustache and
says, David, sir, so much commentary from viewers
who are activated and triggered by any changes to
the show set background guest hosts, your attire,
etc. Please count me in amongst those who
are eagerly tuning in to watch the progress
of the mustache looking better every day, my
friend. That's Scott in New York City. Well,
thank you. You know, I was going to start it only
as a goof, but I'm sort of enjoying the mustache
when people see me who haven't seen me for a few
weeks or a couple of months, I noticed that they
do a double take, but they don't want to bring it
up. And I'll immediately say, it's the mustache,
right? And they can't help but say, Yes, it
is the mustache. This is a satirical mustache,
to be completely clear, but it is generating
interest and intrigue and that is really more
than I can ask for. So I'm going to keep it going.
The shaving has much improved. It's all it's just
it's all going really, really well, is what
I would say. Scott So we're going to keep it
going for the time being. Okay. A couple emails
about my interview with Patrick Brett. David,
When I was down in Florida a couple of weeks ago,
Craig wrote in about the PBD approach to debating.
Craig says You talking about him was the first I'd
heard of him, and he just turned me off. He would
ask you a question that I'm sure you would have
a straightforward answer to, but then you would
immediately present an analogy that he feels would
trick you into answering how he would like. Then
when you ask him straightforward questions,
he wouldn't answer. Instead, he would ask,
Where are you going with this thinking you are
trying to trick him into saying the wrong thing
and he doesn't want to get beat at his own game.
Also, his come on, you're a smart person is very
condescending. I'm curious. Your thoughts. Thanks.
That's Craig from Maui. Yeah, Craig, you're right
about everything you're saying. I thought it was
super interesting. Perfectly nice guy, you know,
And we chatted very briefly before and after the
show and all. All of it and perfectly nice guy.
But I did think that it wasn't necessarily bad
faith. It did seem in a way that he was just so
careful not to fall into any kind of a trap. Like
when I said to him, when you think about the tax
rate you're willing to pay, like, are you willing
to pay more if you get more for your taxes,
like if it included college and health care, would
you be willing to pay more than if it didn't? It
really wasn't a trick question. It was trying to
open a conversation about what we value. And he
was saying something like, Well, I don't think
we're spending it the right way. And I'm like,
That's not the question I'm asking. Sir
Craig's assessment is pretty, pretty spot on,
and maybe I will have another opportunity to try
again. René also wrote in about the interview
with Patrick about David and said, Hi, David, I'm
listening to your chat with Patrick. But David,
I've never heard of this guy, but his
arguments remind me so much of trying to
have a conversation with my stepdad who's good
hearted but so exasperating. I'm not sure if I
can make it through this whole thing because
when you try to pinpoint one issue, he throws
ten other random examples and says, Well, what
about this? What about that? Like lending a bike
to someone is the same as centralizing how we
fund health care. It's so hard to get anywhere
with people who have this worldview. But thank
you for trying. Yeah, this was a very common
sort of email I got. And feedback wise, I think
the most interesting outcome of the Patrick Bat
David interview is that usually the home team
has a huge bias to the host. So for example,
I would expect that when I upload my interviews
with. The comment would be mostly positive about
me. And they were. And I would expect that on his
channel. The video we did would be mostly positive
about him. Interestingly, tons of his viewers
on his channel said in the comments you were
unnecessarily hostile. This didn't go well for
you, Pat, etc., etc.. The fact that that was even
a noticeable portion of the feedback from his
audience is very interesting. I don't know what it
means, but it's certainly very, very interesting
and I would be interested in doing it again.
Nolito wrote in and says, Are you able to
post a link on the main web page for the
Spanish broadcast? I can't find it. David said
it quickly. I didn't catch it. I'm going to say
the link again. With total peace and love. David
Pakman dot com slash Spanish. As of this moment we
have breached 1500 subscribers on the channel and
we got our first video with over a thousand views
on the Spanish channel. It is extraordinarily
exciting, extraordinarily exciting. And we're
going to be putting in a bunch of different
resources into the project because I think it
is so important. Ron wrote in about the Ohio
train derailment, and Ron said something I've
been seeing everywhere. I've been seeing it on
Twitter. I've been seeing it on Reddit. Ron says,
David, can you provide coverage of the Ohio
train derailment? I feel like this is a major
story that should be getting more coverage
but isn't getting the attention it deserves.
I genuinely don't understand why I am seeing
this comment everywhere. There's a narrative
that's developed that nobody's talking about
the train derailment. I see it everywhere. I,
I go to New York Times dot com. It's about the
train derailment. I go to Washington Post train
derailment, Fox News train derailment because they
want to criticize the judge and Joe Biden about
it. Read it all over the train derailment. Twitter
all over the train derailment. Independent media.
We've already done a number of clips about it and
so have many of our colleagues. I am not seeing
that there isn't coverage of this. And I don't
know what people you know, It's happened in other
cases where there's a story that's like everywhere
and you see people saying this, it's not getting
any coverage and yet everybody is talking about
it. I don't really know where that's coming from.
I'd be interested to know more. And if you have
any sense of why that narrative is being repeated.
Let me know, because I am seeing coverage
about every aspect of this. What caused it? The
controlled burn? Mike DeWine. The chemicals. Is
the water safe? Is the air safe? Is the soil safe?
Is this Pete Budda judge's fault or not? Is this
Joe Biden's fault or not? The Obama regulations
that Donald Trump rolled back, I'm seeing every
aspect of the story covered extensively, and it is
an important story. So we should be seeing that.
But I'm just not seeing the lack of coverage. Let
me know if you know where that's coming from.
We have such a great bonus show for you today.
You can sign up so quickly at join Packman
dot com if you want to pay the normal prices.
That's great. I believe that they're eminently
reasonable. Six bucks a month. 60 for the year.
If that strikes you as high for your financial
situation. No problem. I have a coupon code for
you. That code is 24 starts now. The number two at
24 to 4 starts now. No spaces. Okay. 2024 really
does start right now. We're in the middle of
it already. Sign up, you'll get the bonus,
show the commercial free audio and video feeds of
the show, invitations to our members, only town
halls and access to the soundboard. Oh, bum. Now.
Yeah, we have a soundboard in the members section
of the website for our members. Check it out.
We will see you on the bonus show momentarily.